attention couch soldiers to line you the
mainstream establishment is poisoned
your mind they say we should investigate
Trump I say impeach Hillary
they say global warming is made by man
I'd say probably why we earn 30 cent
more on the dollar they say our children
should learn Chinese
I say China isn't real no one I know has
like ever been there and I know like a
ton of people for they the enemy who's
the enemy they are I already said that
pay attention time for us to fight back
against them because them are fighting
against we I'm Jordan Klepper and this
is the opposition the opposition Jordan
Klepper weeknights after The Daily Show
premieres September 25th on Comedy
Central
progress you'll have to go through us
first